james garfield is the only us president  to prove a mathematical theorem he  showed that a squared plus b squared is  equal to c squared how did he do it  duplicate the right triangle and rotate  it 90 degrees clockwise to extend the  side a in a right triangle the acute  angles are complementary thus the angle  between these two triangles is a 90  degree right angle  now connect the rightmost vertices to  construct a trapezoid the area is the  average of the parallel sides a and b  multiplied by the height a plus b but we  can also calculate the area of the  trapezoid as the sum of the areas of  three triangles two triangles have an  area of one-half times a b the other  triangle has an area of one half times c  squared simplify the equation by  removing a factor of one half from both  sides  then expand the binomial and subtract  two a b from both sides thus a squared  plus b squared is equal to c squared  what an incredible proof